[Musique]
bonjour abdurahman azat carrière merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france ce soir
alors le dépouillement des scrutins il
est en cours est ce qu'on peut espérer
des premières tendances cette nuit
quelles sont les informations dont vous
disposez bonsoir électorale nationale
indépendante à peine de commencer de
donner les résultats du scrutin à l'état
pas où nous sommes nous ne pouvons
donner aucune tendance
les bleu poudre va continuer et on va
jusqu'à ce que la tendance se dégage ce
panel est là qu on vient de vous
préciser qu' au regard de la force du
pnds tarayya l'échiquier politique
national
au regard du travail que le pnds pendant
toutes ces années au regard de la
méthode et d'une approche du pnds
tarayya qui a toujours été aux côtés des
masses aux côtés du peuple et de nos
populations
on peut aisément affirmer sans risque de
se tromper
nous sommes très fiers a dit ci dessus
ce critère nous sommes très pauvres aux
élections locales
une tendance se dégage et nous sommes
très loin devant tous les partis
politiques c'est un raz de marée et à
cela vient s'ajouter la pluie le soutien
que les autres partis politiques ont
apporté à notre ville
alors on a des petits soucis liaison
mais je pense qu'on va arranger ça donc
vous êtes en mesure d'affirmer sur des
bases solides c'est à dire des bases
issu de la commission électorale que le
pnds le parti au pouvoir une bonne
assise au moment où on se parle on est
en contact avec les populations
c'est un parti qui est à l'écouté sur
les jt nous de nos différentes
populations sur la base desquels le pnd
et n'avoir son programme de kaman
je l'avais du tout à l'heure à l'égard
des résultats des élections locales
vu la ferme à distance les autres partis
plus bien évidemment le rapport soutient
que nous sommes alors justement le
candidat de votre parti mohamed bazoum
il est considéré comme le dauphin du
président sortant mamadou issoufou qui a
tenu sa promesse puisque il ne n'est pas
en lice pour un troisième mandat mais
que répondez vous à ceux qui affirment
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'alternance
démocratique mais d'une continuité du
pouvoir finalement parce qu'il est
présenté comme le dauphin du président
sortant qu'il n'y a pas je vais vous
dire que c'est pour la première fois une
situation inédite dans notre pays qu'il
y aura un passage de témoin démocratique
entre un président démocratiquement élu
et notre président qui sera
démocratiquement élu par le peuple
nigérien
c'est justement à ce niveau qu'il faut
apprécier ce qu'on pourrait appeler alta
mais moi je parlerais de passage
démocratique de témoin maintenant il
faut aussi se dire que le mérite revient
d'abord au président de la république
son excellence ils se font mamatou qui a
tenu sa promesse
je n'ai rien changé dans la constitution
et de ne pas se présenter pour un
troisième mandat
notre aspect notre mérite qui lui
revient
c'est justement leur aspect qu'il a
toujours fait des principes et des
valeurs démocratiques
il a créé les conditions d'élections
libres transparentes et démocratiques
claque aujourd'hui la toujours prôné
aujourd'hui à l'épreuve de fait que ce
soir au niger ou ailleurs nous
constatons que les élections se sent
très bien passé
les élections se sont passées de manière
purement pratiques et les élections ont
été bien organisées
nonobstant le pentax sécuritaires
difficiles dans lesquelles nous sommes
donc il faut saluer le mérite et il faut
aussi reconnaître le mérite du président
est de la nationale
il ya un contexte il ya un contexte
sécuritaire compliqué mais visiblement
l'engouement des électeurs est à faire
les nigériens ont voté massivement hier
vous confirmez bien sûr jamais sorti il
s'en sortait avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé
il ya eu beaucoup d'engouement dans tout
le pays
il y avait la bonne humeur qui se lisait
sur le visage de nos compatriotes et de
nos concitoyens les nigériens était
satisfait d'avoir fauté et ils seront
satisfaits qui suit des hommes alors
s'agissant du président sortant mamadou
issoufou
vous l'avez évoqué la lui-même
après avoir voté hier parlé d'un jour
particulier pour lui synonyme
d'alternance démocratique sur quoi
précisément se font de cet interne ans
démocratique fondée que bien sûr mais si
fragile iversen l'alternance
démocratique ses bases
c'est la souveraineté populaire
appartient aux peuvent se le faire pour
les nigériens qui va se prononcer c'est
le peuple algérien qui va décider qui va
à l'issue de ce critère c'est cela la
démocratie
alors je voudrais vous entendre sur une
polémique qui a été alimenté beaucoup
par l'opposition qui a contesté la
candidature de mohamed bazoum plusieurs
opposants affirment qu'ils ne disposent
pas de la nationalité d'origine exigé
par la constitution pour être éligible à
la magistrature suprême au niger que
dites-vous sur le fond de cette
polémique exécrable
en réalité cela on soulève cette
question n a fait que faire de la
diversion pourquoi parce que non pas de
billard ils n'ont pas de programme
ils n'ont rien à proposer vos papilles
girerd
donc ils versent dans des questions
vraiment exécrable
quant à ce qu'ils aient cette question
des nationalités je vous dis que
derrière nous la cour constitutionnelle
a déjà tranché le président bazin et
nigérienne origines et dans tous les cas
dans tous les cas la ceni à prom a cédé
dépouiller les résultats sur le peuple
nigérien
il va décider si par son pdg répond pas
et nous le saurons très bientôt alors le
le salou djibo le chef de la junte
militaire de 2010 qui avait renversé
mamadou tandja et il a même décidé lui
de saisir la cour constitutionnelle pour
qu'elle clarifie 7 la situation de
mohamed bazoum
est ce que il ya des craintes d'une
forte contestation dans la rue si
mohamed bazoum est élu d'abord comme
vous l'avez constaté et internationale a
constaté les nigériens sont sortis
massivement enthousiastes ont pour que
les nigérians forte des cas les
nigériens ont voté c'est pour
effectivement choisir un président parmi
les différents candidats
donc il n'aura vraiment pas d n'aura pas
vraiment pas de contestation et dans
tous les cas la cour constitutionnelle a
débouté mais a débouté le général sa
bouche juste cette dernière question
plus que l'opposition a beaucoup sus
tiges et l'inefficacité du pouvoir face
aux questions sécuritaires mohamed
bazoum fin l'ex ministre de l'intérieur
il promet lui de combattre boko haram
comment est-ce qu'il va tenir sa
promesse parce qu'on sait que les
multiples tentatives justement pour
juguler la secte islamiste nigériane a
été quand même mitigé
ces dernières années la capacité du
régime à n'est pas jugulée la sécurité
est un faux procès je rectifie si vous
constatez la position du niger
on peut dire sans risque de se tromper
que j'arrête rpi bien sécurisé tout aimé
mars viennent de l'extérieur
et rassurez vous permettez moi de vous
le précisez aussi il a aucune parcelle
de notre territoire qui est occupée par
le triste et je vous dis que tu as le
travail bien fait et est accompli par le
président pour maintenant le président
bas
plus les consolider ses acquis de
consolider ses avoirs et des victoires
et nous avons eu un déficit comme hiver
pour avancer et dans tous les cas c'est
and the city a de l'expérience là était
plus verte de la majorité c'est un homme
d'état il saura capitaliser les affaires
merci beaucoup à vous à doha macharia je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du candidat mohamed bazoum le candidat
du parti au pouvoir pnd f